welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Tony to copal and
Anthony Mason is under self-quarantine
it is New York City home out of an
abundance of caution he is okay we're
going to talk to him later on as a
number of coronavirus cases continues to
climb we're hearing from emergency room
staff who say they will soon run out of
supplies Rina 9 and of our streaming
service at CBS n spoke with dr. Gillian
Schmitz the vice president of the
American College of Emergency Physicians
across er's in America they are so
desperate for supplies what are you
doing now to meet the need this is our
pride and joy of taking care of anyone
anywhere anytime and but the situation
has become really desperate to the point
where most of us have maybe at best 72
hours worth of equipment left in our
Hospital some have already run out
completely and we're being forced to
sort of improvise and make up equipment
I've seen people using the plastic
protector sheets for their kids homework
to put in as a is a face mask I've seen
people even wearing ski goggles and
Halloween costumes that were masked to
try and cover up parts of their face and
there's not a whole lot of good evidence
to say that what we're doing is even
state 4 so for instance this is a
droplet mask that I have and it's a thin
mask if someone costs in my face I don't
get wet but this is not enough it's
simply a shield it doesn't have the
level of protection that we need is
wouldn't be acceptable in any other
field if we were going to war we would
send people in with you know guns and
shields and ammunition to help them win
this fight she makes a good point you
can see rayna's full interview with dr.
Schmitz on our streaming service at CBS
n